honnêtement moi j'étais téléspectateurs
j'ai été téléspectateurs système on n'a
pas nous on n'a pas six c'est un débat
c'est un débat sicile après le lendemain
on vient où on a toujours un truc ou
dire oui mais je vais pas venir parce
que c'est la seule touche trop moi je
comprends mathieu qui soit touché
énormément touché moi aussi j'ai été
touché par plein de débat ça m'empêche
pas d'être revenu le lendemain ici
géraldine a été touché par une main de
débats valérie bénaïm aussi gilles
raymond lemay aujourd'hui d'accord mais
l'est il a peut-être non non non non
attendez vie d'hommes homosexuels année
où l'homophobie ça on le comprend les
homosexuels ayant le meilleur moyen
c'est le meilleur moyen sans jugement
j'ai reçu d'aidé des messages de
dizaines d'homosexuels de transe combat
de nos textes vient bien sûr non je sais
mais j'ai reçu des dizaines de messages
les gens ont été touchés par la séquence
honnêtement elle était très difficile à
regarder pour un homosexuel parce que
aujourd'hui autour de la table je suis
désolé ya pas d'homophobe clairement
mais par contre mc pro b tu te dire s'il
y en avait ne serait pas dans l'édition
des propos comme le nouveau god et comme
le racisme parfois ces systèmes une
accusation des six tenir mon encontre
oui oui je suis désolé je vais te
rappeler un de détroit monde sait que je
vais te rappeler un de tenir sa grille
ni moi ne sommes homophobes est ce que
tu es choqué par la condamnée par le
fait que des pays condamnent
l'homosexualité tu n'as pas voulu
répondre ça c'est pour toi m'interroge
je suis désolé non mais non des raymond
je suis désolé si je vais parce que
vraiment je trouve qu'au tour la table
ya eu plusieurs personnes qui auraient
dû réagir autrement et je ne comprends
pas votre réaction
pour donner des idées qui ne lui
correspondent pas l'homosexualité n'est
pas une idée c'est pas un contre
l'homophobie n'est pas une idée
exactement guillaume tu as dit en france
on est dans un pays qui prône la liberté
d'expression on a le droit d'être neutre
sur un sujet ce n'est pas un sujet qui
est remise à par géraldine homosexualité
c'est un survival et non non c'est non
non non non
si vous voulez c'est moi qui contrôle de
la sexualité dans ce calme et s'il vous
plaît non moi je vais vous dire pour moi
hier
moi je comprends tout à fait le la
position de matthieu delormeau bien sûr
et on l'a on la comprend tous ici après
gilles à sa position il a expliqué ça ne
fait pas de gilles un homophobe voilà et
ça je n'accepterai jamais qu'un
chroniqueur trade gilles d'homophobe si
gilles je le redis et homophobe il
serait pas autour de la table après
match comme si c'était mathieu d'europe
mais voit c'est une relation c'est une
c'est une réaction à la situation
si ça doit tuer tout nu des propos qui
sont à la limite il s'est désolé car ces
occasions de but mais non mais gilles à
une réaction inverse mathieu parce que
voilà je connais voilà parce qu'il ait
il était bien dit de raciste mais il ne
lui manque rien dit d'autre et importe
quoi aussi matthieu delormeau n'est pas
raciste voilà j'ai eu alors qu'il ya eu
des plans à b j'évite homos comme sale
mais juste écoute moi bien ici c'est moi
qui fixe les règles et matthieu
delormeau gilles verdez aujourd'hui il
est là matthieu delormeau aujourd'hui
n'est pas là mais la vérité c'est que
pour le même débat pour le même débat
sur le racisme autour de la table tout
le monde aurait dit la même chose quand
il s'agit de soit sexuellement
deux aubin voilà je peux essayer de
placer quand même une petite bille comme
quoi on n'est pas tout à fait ok avec
1,52 chose le racisme tout le monde
ferme sa gueule non mes gosses almadies
moi le débat est ce qu a dit mathieu
c'est bon on n'a pas besoin de
commentaire ce qu'a dit mathieu hier
pour la plupart y en a beaucoup qui sont
d'accord avec mathieu et on comprend
tout à fait même gilles je pense qu'on
prend tout à fait lundi ses adieux après
un moment il faut venir défendre ses
idées en plateau et ne pas voilà se dit
en russie on vient une fois on revient
pas le lendemain oui je suis touché je
suis pas touché ici on fait on fait de
la télévision où on est dans un débat
l'imaginer c'est un jour en politique et
il fait un débat puis lendemain dia non
mais on a été trop sèchement pauline six
que mathieu et puis c'est un être humain
il a sa sensibilité peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui ils n'avaient pas les
armes notion écologique pour être là
mais il le fera il reviendra mais
j'espère j'espère vraiment pas ce qu'il
est il est super qu'il aura une
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il aura une
discussion avec jean parce que c'est pas
vous étiez peut-être trop tôt pas on
peut pas parler comme ça juste
il ya kirikou le vrai qu'ils étaient
avec nous vous qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé hier ne s'était passé parce que
vous êtes très proche de la barben soir
j'espère que vous allez bien à nous ça
déjà il ya une définition déjà pour vous
c'est quoi la liberté
pour vous je m'adresse à tout le monde
sur le plateau liberté c'est faire se
sait faire ce qu'on ce qu'on a envie de
faire sans faire chier les autres enfin
son numéro aux autres meilleurs pouvoir
d'agir dans une société organisée selon
sa propre dette détermination dans la
limite de régler d'accord le mot phobie
cerveau du coup le mot famille ça fait
pas partie des règles du jeu mais vas-y
vas-y excuse moi je t'écoute plupart des
alors donc cotiser les rides empirique
ouais d'accord le ferai je pense qu'il
est dans les règles de quoi quoi il est
en quoi les pas de regarder qui rend
cette dans le gigantisme
qui n'a pas mention dans son dans son
antre qu'est ce qui est de mon fort en
fait je vais donner un exemple tout bête
quand genre floyd s'est fait tué par la
police aux états unis on est d'accord il
ya eu un mouvement qui a suivi derrière
black les metteurs et ses chiens donc ça
veut dire que si par exemple il ya eu
des joueurs de foot on leur a demandé de
mettre un genou à terre levé le lever le
poing etc non il ya des joueurs qui ne
l'ont pas fait c'est très fier d'eux ça
fait deux ça fait 2 b raciste non mais
n'a pour moi tout et qui fait toute
l'équipe moratti choix cette année à six
mois six
jours grasset le sujet c'est parce que
ça concerne le l'homosexualité que ça
pose problème mais pour que le racisme
tout le monde aurait mis t-shirt donc
pourquoi mais le mouvement lgbt c'est un
mouvement s'est pas être l'homophobie ou
c'est un mouvement c'est un mouvement
qui existe avec des journées comme ça où
ils sont représentés et où on demande au
piano qui est le plus médiatisé le sport
le sport le plus exemplaire delà de
notre pays de montrer le bon exemple est
de montrer que oui en effet maintenant
être homophobe c'est quelque chose qui
ne doit plus exister et malheureusement
là l'exemple est complètement inversé
qu'en mai les couleurs ce sont les
couleurs de lgbt ce ne sont pas des
couleurs de luttre contre l'homophobie
bah si c'était le maillot de lutte
contre l'homophobie c'était le les
couleurs je vous parlais de moi je vous
parle des couleurs parce que c'est les
couleurs qui met la
symbolique bien sûr que si c'était des
maillots c'est quoi la lutte contre
l'homophobie monsieur on n'a pas demandé
à gueye c'est une la gay pride ou de
faire un colloque sur l'homosexualité a
demandé de porter un maillot d'accord
ont prouvé qu'ils étaient contre les
violences faites aux homosexuels
aujourd'hui en france on tabasse des
gens parce qu'ils sont homosexuels parce
qu'ils sont lgbt est ce que ça vous le
condamnez ou pas ou est ce que vous avez
programme bah non c'est un problème type
de violence 8 août a fait tout tout type
de violence je suis sombre affectionne
un genre que je condamne le lomo feu
l'homophobie cch je ne suis pas du genre
répond je condamne l'antisémitisme je ne
suis pas musulmane je combats je
condamne l' islamophobie voilà donc
laissez moi parce qu'il est sympa et le
malaise nourri pourquoi il avait apporté
il a partout vous avez porté un t-shirt
boiteuse madoff mais moi je ne
comprenais pas alors c'est
ce que je ferai avec des joueuses de
tennis une championne ou une
footballeuse j'aurais été très habile it
et pourtant pourquoi elle n'avait pas
fait
cesser
les combats
faire le débat en train de donner des
exemples pour que vous compreniez le
point de vue
on va pas refaire le débat c'est bien
une question du président c'est très
bien on va faire le va pas refaire le
débat c'est vrai qu'on parle de
l'altercation et matthieu delormeau hier
après vous poserai des questions oui
pour moi je comprends que mathieu réagi
dans l'émotion parce que c'est un sujet
qu'il touche mais moi je vous avais on
soutenir gilles à 100% parce que déjà il
était très très mal après l'émission il
était extrêmement touchée et quand on
regarde la séquence déjà sur la forme in
attaqué personne et sur le fond pardon
mais il n'a quasiment pas donner son
avis la fecq expliquer la position
d'idrissa gueye et on ne peut pas le
traité d'homophobe comme ça gilles d'un
côté gauche molle il l'a attaqué
personne les gens se sont sentis
attaqués jean-louis mais parce que les
ce que nous tous venus dire qu'ils
avaient
commencé le soutenir gillis et léger son
travail de journaliste ne tient pas il
explique sa position il aurait fait ça
voilà sportif il fait son travail de
journaliste il se fait chier alors que
tu trouvais ça c'était sa liberté de
conscience la liberté de conscience et
l'ontario manos où j'ai tenté
d'expliquer pourquoi le joueur
sénégalais musulmans idrissa gana guèye
ne portait pas ce symbole en quoi ça ne
reflétait pas sa confiance j'ai dû
appeler d'année sont souvent direction
expliquez moi si on me demandait de
porter ces symboles je le porterai
fièrement des comptes mafieux
mathieu a besoin que verizon mathieu a
besoin que tu que tu condamnes l'aj
auxerre mais qui te demande si le fait
que des pays condamnent l'homosexualité
à l'étranger tout choc tu ne réponds pas
vocation les jeunes arrivaient de la
provocation ou je dis simplement que je
le parlais d'expliquer j'ai tenté de
comprendre j'ai compris quoi il pouvait
heurter la susceptibilité la sensibilité
des sénégalais ou des musulmans en
faisant ça pourquoi pour lui et notre
sensibilité à nour mais pourquoi pour
lui c'était impossible c'est ce que j'ai
voulu dire j'ai pas dit que je
comprenais son geste - gilles verdez
j'ai voulu faire benoît la question